so season two of daredevil is finally
out that means two things firstly it
means I'm getting a awful lot less work
done because I'm watching that series
secondly it means it's that time of year
where I often go around the kitchen to
make breakfast with my eyes closed and
make a terrible mess
I'm not daredevil however there is a
scientifically sound way in which
someone could become more like daredevil
and I'm going to talk to you about that
in this video because otherwise that
would be a very random and somewhat
cruel introduction to a video
so how might one become more like
daredevil for starters we're going to do
away with becoming blind that's not our
objective here although there's many
ways you could do that if you want to
instead I'm going to focus on hiking the
other sentences and also while we're at
it why don't we heighten sight as well
so how we're going to do this when it is
actually possible through a process
called neural plasticity if you've been
reading my blog or watching it in my
other videos which I hope you have then
you should know what this is it's the
brain's ability to create new create new
connections between nerve cells even to
birth new brain cells through a process
called neurogenesis essentially ready
that's like a muscle reaches out its
tendrils lays down new connections this
is how you learn new skills that's how
you lay down new memories and you can
also use it to completely develop
entirely new skills and to change your
very perception of reality when you're
born your brain is like a blank slate
until you interact with the world you
create the specific network of neurons
that you have which is called a
connectome and that defines who you are
how we see the world and if you were
raised in a different environment then
you have a completely different
connector and your brain works in
entirely different ways and an example
of this is if you're blind raised from
birth blind then you don't about all the
same connections that you normally would
do around visual cortex you do develop
more connections associated your
deployed cortex and your other senses
and this is just because you're using
them while you're practicing learn more
thus you're creating new connections
you're focusing on the more and yeah you
get super hearing of course you can't
dodge bullet like daredevil cat
in fact you still need a white cane just
to find a way around in most cases but
there are cases of people who develop
this hearing to the extent that they can
use echolocation which is the closest
thing to what daredevil is depicted as
doing in the TV series of the comics so
echolocation is the ability to find your
way around like a bat you're sending out
sound waves and waiting for them to
bounce back to you just determining the
environment around you it's like so much
so if you speak and you wait the echo to
come back in the echo takes a long time
that means that you're a wider room if
it bounces back very quickly let me do
in a small room so so on with
echolocation can make small tick noises
and use this decipher the shape of the
wall around them so they don't have as
good ability to tell what's going on
around them but someone like Ben
Underwood
he's one case of somebody you imagine
develop this skill to such a degree
despite being blind you can play
football you can ride a bike it's insane
and although we might be superior in
some tasks he would stand a better
chance of dodging a fist coming from
behind it so the question that someone
like me obviously asks because I'm
insane is can someone who isn't blind
develop echolocation and the answer that
is you know in theory yes but probably
it's going to be incredibly difficult to
get to that extent you probably never
will always be honest like most blind
people don't get to that point there are
schools and courses I think on develop
this kind of ability but most people
never get that far who are blind even
from birth so your chances when you're
closing your eyes in the kitchen like me
a swing so in doing my research to find
out how I might accomplish this I've
read some blog posts son said to walk
around making whistling noise and
purposely stand close to a wall to learn
what that sounds like and gradually move
away and notice the different
and that's fine advice but it's not
going to help in the long run it's it's
you know interesting but you have to do
this every single day and it's too
contextually sensitive just yeah it's
not going to make you into daredevil
overnight so what you want to focus on
instead is the next best thing which is
something called sound localization now
this is something that can be trained I
know guys improve the sound localization
it's the ability to know where a sound
is coming from and this is useful if for
instance your sound engineer who lays
out microphones for recording symphonies
or film schools so what they do is they
can tell how far away a sound is and how
loud it is versus directions coming from
etc and one phone settings sometimes as
he did at Tom Meister course which
basically is a sound engineering course
he would be blindfolded and people would
be around him they make a noise enhancer
to tell where they came from that they
could actually improve this sound
localization and these are people have
no interest in becoming their level I
don't know what's wrong with them but
what you can do then is you can use this
just to become better at knowing where
you are based on that contextual
information so if you're walking down
the street your eyes are closed
you can hear how far away the cars are
you know roughly how far onto the curb
you are or how place of road you're I
don't recommend walking this doing this
near a busy break because you will get
killed and it will probably sort of my
faults are there do it and the thing is
you don't need to be actively training
this it can actually just be more
mindful of it all the time just when
you're walking down the road be more
aware to soundscape think about where
the sounds are coming from
where they are in relation to the things
you can see I feel the ground of make
your feet wind on your face and the
sounds coming in from all directions
just by being more aware of these things
you're training them and that's
something to do much more religiously
and frequently than just some kind of
practice where you walk around your
house with your eyes closed by being
more mindful and aware of your
environment you can start to build a far
more cohesive picture of the world
around you so that you couldn't then
navigate a little bit better with your
eyes closed
because the other senses you know or
wherever and that's actually another big
point attention and focus generally
because we're actually very bad at it we
tend to be focused on just one thing we
have our attention tends to be on where
we're going what we're thinking about
often we're very reserved and in fact
you can watch a video and be completely
unaware of something very key happening
in it there's this one video where
people are throwing a ball between each
other who has to watch the ball when you
watch the ball a gorilla walks
forgiveness and psychology will show you
this in a psychology lecture a gorilla
walks through the crowd and because
you're watching the ball you completely
miss that huge grill it's a man in a
gorilla costume to be not real good
they'll end up in bloodshed but yeah
factly watching the movie typically they
see the gorilla so if you want to
improve your psychic is sound and
everything else just being more aware is
a great idea and it's very hard to be
more aware because you can't remind
yourself you forget doing other things
and you forget to pay attention the
world around you so you need your prompt
and you know something like meditation
or mindfulness practice in general can
help you to just be more aware of the
surroundings and thus more ready as well
for if somebody were to attack you
regardless of how good your senses up
you need to be paying attention to them
for them to be any use to you so I said
we be looking at sight as well how can
you improve your site well actually the
same way that you improve the hearing
just as there's neuroplasticity
there's also visual plasticity and you
can change the density of the
photoreceptors that intake in I am light
and happy to see you can actually
improve your visual resolution and this
is possible because the eyes in some
sense is the only external part of your
brain so they can develop in just the
same way as any other part of your brain
through practice and once again you can
thicken your
cortex and create more connections there
by being more alert to it and more
attentive and this is why that some
studies show playing computer games
specifically action games actually
increases your visual acuity you
increase your sensitivity to small dots
on the horizon even your ability to
decipher the differences between similar
colors specifically grave in the study
so if you the same would be true for
sports because you're looking at the
horizon you're looking out for the ball
you're trying to be aware of everyone on
the pitch basically use it or lose it
and so if you're training yourself from
these kind of scenarios where a lot of
attention is required focused on your
vision you can actually develop better
vision of course there's a lot more than
just visual acuity the impacts you're
related to see you have things like the
lens itself your muscles surrounding
your eye on your ability to change their
strength to alter the shape of the lens
you have things like your ability to
track things with your eyes visual
tracking all these can be trained as
well but they require separate things
and if you have some kind of problem
with your eyesight then you know there's
only so much that improving a visual
acuity can do I've spoken a lot more
about all these things on my blog post
called how to train your senses like
daredevil very novel idea that was and
if you're going to check that out you
can learn you know about nutrition about
exercises for strengthening your nerves
and even how to improve your smell
that's ironic because I'm a Gnostic I
have no sense of smell
apparently sniffing your own sweat can
increase the number of receptors in your
nose and help me to smell better but it
wouldn't do anything for me because yeah
I can't smell anything just weird and
you think I'd have heightened senses
like daredevil but no I've just got a
big nose that can't smell so thanks for
that but yeah check that if you want a
lot more detailed information on this
but for now my take-home messages but
being more mindful of your surroundings
and obvious senses can help you to
increase the new density relating to
those senses and this can help you to
have more awareness of the world around
you and what's wrong that subject I also
would recommend looking in
my post on synesthesia this is how you
could mix senses a lot of people are
born with synesthesia that's the ability
for instance seed sounds as colors or to
experience letters as colors or for
instance to hear sounds smells it's
where senses cross over and as I was
talking cross modality is actually very
important I was talking earlier about
how you could use your eye base to hear
and see the distance of something in
order to create a more complete picture
of the world around you that's a type of
cross modality synesthesia takes us to
the next level and it's got some awesome
applications and studies showing that
you can train and improve synesthesia
just through practice if you read lots
and lots of books where the letters of
different colors eventually you will see
those letters as colors by creating the
associations and the corresponding newer
connections so read up on that on my
website or there's also a video on it on
my channel which you can check out so do
that and all these things that input for
the brain and if you think of the brain
like a computer then the way you hack
any system is by looking at the
influence and how you can manipulate
notice your senses are some of the
biggest influence so there's all kinds
of things you could cheat by improving
the senses final all engines dodging
bullets dead before style you could
potentially change the regulation thing
and possibly improve things like memory
or pattern recognition through enhanced
senses and practicing rhythms so yeah
there's a lot to think about here and
I'll be posting a lot more on in the
future both videos and blog posts so if
you're interested stick around please
like share and subscribe and I'll
catching the next video thanks very much
for watching bye for now